on remonte dans le temps maintenant
envoyer la photo de joleil campeau qui a
été assassiné c'est en 1995 ça fait 19
ans vient le procès d'eric daudelin qui
est accusé de ce meurtre vient de
commencer au palais de justice de laval
les 14 jurés ont été choisis aujourd'hui
le procès devrait durer un mois
jacques bissonnet des dizaines de
candidats jurés ont défilé devant le
tribunal et 14 d'entre eux ont été
retenus pour ce procès huit hommes et
six femmes
eric dodelet maintenant âgé de 39 ans
fait face à trois chefs d'accusation
meurtre prémédité de la petite joleil
campeau 9 ans agression sexuelle et
séquestration
la fillette a été portée disparue le 12
juin 1995 dans le secteur auteuil à
laval des temps se recherche effectuée
par les policiers et de nombreux
bénévoles se sont alors déroulés et le
corps de l'enfant a finalement été
retrouvé près de chez elle
quatre jours après sa disparition éric
daudelin a été arrêté à montréal en juin
il est apparu en cours l'air détendu est
demeuré impassible pendant le choix des
jurés
un certain moment cependant il a voulu
s'adresser ses avocats et la juge sophie
bourque qui préside ce procès est bien
la vitre réprimander et il lui a demandé
de garder le silence
alors éric daudet a par la suite
assister à l'audience sans broncher et
sans manifester d'émotion il a plaidé
non coupable aux trois chefs
d'accusation qui pèsent contre lui
ce procès doit durer au moins un mois
la couronne a déjà indiqué qu'elle
appellera neuf témoins à la barre des
policiers pour la plupart au cours des
prochains jours des requins doivent être
débattues mais en l'absence du jury
l'audition des premiers témoins est
prévue le 10 mars prochain
après la relâche scolaire issigeac
bissonnet radio-canada laval